it's a graduating class on the path for
a stellar future on Friday 13 men and
women celebrated their completion of
NASA's Artemis astronaut training
program and are now candidates for
future missions which could include a
trip to the moon and possibly the planet
Mars we spoke with one of the recent
graduates about the journey he just
completed and about the amazing ones
that could lie ahead in 1969 astronaut
Neil Armstrong captivated the world
making history as the first human to
step foot on the lunar surface more than
a half-century later NASA graduated the
newest class of astronauts at the
Johnson Space Center in Houston without
further ado let's welcome the world's
newest astronauts to the stage
Raja Chari was one of 13 candidates
chosen out of a record-setting 18,000
applicants to join the ranks as a NASA
astronaut I was wondering if maybe it
was a prank call I you know people think
I'm being humble when I when I say I
didn't expect to be called but I
honestly did not expect to be called
charese class is the first to graduate
under the Artemis program with Artemis
the whole plan is to have a sustainable
infrastructure and to use the moon as a
proving ground to go to Mars and beyond
the hope is to send the next man and
first woman to the moon by 2024 this
would be the first manned mission to the
moon since the 1970s and if all systems
are go the astronauts will be able to
stay on the moon's surface for extended
periods of time pushing the limits of
human exploration that's I think what's
most exciting to me is it's the idea of
developing technology and honestly
things we don't even know about most of
the discoveries on the space station and
from Apollo are not things that the
scientists originally expected some of
the most brilliant things in terms of
you know modern computing and stuff like
that or are things no one really
anticipated they just fell out of out of
that effort and so when you put American
ingenuity and resources into that goal I
think we'll be amazed
20 years from now the things that fall
out of that
I love seeing from one of the astronauts
it was a book report on space that got
her interested in going book reports a
good thing I love our Raj said he
thought it was a prank call
you